[Music]
here's a cube that's placed on the table
we know that if we are pushing the cube
in this direction then the force of
friction will act in the opposite
direction if we apply a force along the
left then the force of friction will act
towards the right and vice-versa
the force of friction will always oppose
the applied force what are the factors
that affect the friction let me give you
three situations and then you tell me
what it depends on the first situation
is when an object with a smooth surface
is moving on a surface which is very
smooth second in which the object has a
smooth surface and the surface on which
it moves is rough or the object has a
rough surface and the surface on which
it moves is smooth and in the third case
the surface of the object as well as the
surface of the table is rough in which
situation do you think will the force of
friction be the highest intuitively you
will tell me that in the third case the
force of friction will be higher than
these two cases and in which situation
will the force of friction be the lowest
it'll be the first case as both the
surfaces are very smooth though there
will be friction here it will be lesser
than that in the other two cases if we
just look at these three situations we
can say that the force of friction
increases as we go towards the right so
can you tell me the first factor on
which the force of friction depends yes
it depends on the nature of the surface
on which the object moves and the nature
of the surface of the object yes it
depends on the smoothness or the
roughness of the two surfaces which are
in contact with each other if you want
to find out if this is true here's what
you can do at home create an inclined
slope on a table like this and Mark a
point somewhere on it now from this
point let a small cylindrical shaped
object move down you will see that it
reaches a particular point and then stir
next place sandpaper right under the
slope and leave the object from the same
point as before what do you notice you
will see that the distance covered by
the object is lesser in the second case
and you probably know why the surface on
which the object rolled was rougher in
the second case and clearly the force of
friction was more why is friction caused
though it is caused due to the
irregularities on the two surfaces in
contact what do I mean by irregularities
now even though the table looks smooth
if we zoom into the surface we will see
the surface irregularities even the
surface of the object has irregularities
though they are minor they still exist
now the irregularities on the surfaces
lock into one another so whenever we
have to move an object we need to
overcome the irregularities but why is
the friction higher on rough surfaces
it's because rougher the surfaces more
will be the irregularities and if the
irregularities are more then more force
will be required to overcome them so the
first factor affecting the friction is
the nature of surfaces is there any
other factor you can think of let's say
there are two bricks on a table one
weighs two kilograms and the other
weighs five kilograms now I apply equal
force on them towards the right which
brick do you think will go further
remember that they are both kept on the
same surface and the surfaces of the
bricks are also the same uh applying the
same amount of force you will notice
that the lighter brick covered more
distance than the heavier one what does
this tell us it tells us that the
friction also depends on the force with
which the two surfaces are pressed
together if the two surfaces are pressed
harder the friction will be more why is
that because of the second bricks
greater weight it presses on the table
with greater force since its surface
and the table surface are pressed
together harder the interlocking between
the irregularities is more and this
results in more friction so mainly there
are two things on which the force of
friction depends the nature of both
surfaces and the force with which the
two surfaces are pressed together
[Music]